set up
sit up
[Music]
i'm not drunk i haven't had anything to
drink come on you're gonna be
drunk come on i haven't had anything
no you you can give me give me all bring
your breathalyzer bring out your
breathalyzer
bring out your breathalyzer
[Music]
get on
grab
get out of me
get out me okay bro no love
i ain't broke no love
get out of me hello
[Music]
i bet you i hate myself soon as i get
enough you know you know i don't care
even more away one way to keep yourself
i know what you tell me and more than
one way to kill yourself
yeah
get everyone no
no y'all better knock me out and i gotta
i gotta i gotta fling i stand in my
heart
come on bro
no why my brother
oh
got outside clue
[Music]
it should be flesh
let's see this shit
all right anyway he's a winner
all
uh
foreign
[Music]
and shit
ain't gonna worry about it
all right oh know what you're saying
about it like
no i just i just said you said flashing
yeah it should be a little
little black thing with a little blue
light flash
oh you know what it ain't going to be
flash because you want to thank you
you know
all right
[Music]
we're getting them out it's gonna be
forty six thousand two hundred left
two four twenty miles one point six two
one one zero zero fifty eight
uh
brown
that shit i love myself
you wanna call emily she's still
breathing go ahead
i'll tell you something here she getting
up back door
sit up go ahead set up
i need to check out
yeah
she jumped out the car
let's be myself
go ahead
i'm getting a 10 18.
i'll tell you seven haircuts
send a single to 10 18.
[Music]
car how your back does but that's
really ready to report them just saying
you know like you said you got a hot
back door
we're gonna talk you know
but uh we're good
keep it checked
brianna
come on this is deputy prime come on
ain't got no caught in the water don't
worry about it
oh i gotta live
hold it right here
bro
i i really can't tell but i don't think
so
i really couldn't tell but i don't
believe so though i don't know